und anstatt dem skelett kann ich da
beispielsweise einfach mal noch mal sein
eingeben und jetzt habe ich quasi eine
giganten der einen gegangen hätte ich
bei der lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen in folge bei knapp 6 laut
blatt befinden wir uns gerade am 23 wenn
alles passen hochgeladen wurden ich
hatte natürlich wieder ein bisschen
recherchierten hat ein paar facts von
roche genommen paar von mir aus dem
forum das wiki bleiben und so weiter und
so fort es würde mich freuen wenn die
bis zum ende dran bleiben würde und
eventueller video bewerten würde aber
das macht am besten nach dem video weil
wir das erstmal zuschauen muss damit ihr
wisst ob es gut oder schlecht auf ihren
daumen hoch oder daumen im b final four
am mittag nur eins ist eine sache da
habe ich mir gedacht okay ihr kennt
vielleicht noch die folge von irgendwann
mal wo ich zwei spyder jobs gespannt
habe das ist einfach so ein zufall und
zwar habe ich danach bei facebook
einfach mal ein bild hochgeladen was ich
euch jetzt mal eine blende und zwar habe
ich mal recherchiert also ich habe
wirklich einen spinnens pony genommen
habt auf den boden gesetzt und spider
jockey bekommen da dachte ich mir fand
man die chancen beider jockey zu
bekommen ist
0,01
moment moment moment als 100 doch
richtig und zwar die chance einen spider
jockey spawn wenn man ein ganz normales
spindler hat es 0,01 prozent also 1 100
also von 100 versuchen die man da auf
dem boden rechts macht mit dem spyder
mit dem spyder eck kommt ein mann spyder
jockey und deswegen muss man einfach die
beiden also 0,01 mal 0,01 multiplizieren
dann ist die chance bei spider jockey
hintereinander zu spawnen 0,0001 prozent
dieses wertes bild eingeblendet was ich
bei facebook hochgeladen habe und zwar
es war halt wirklich so also die folge
müsst ihr einfach mal gucken in
minecraft ich glaube das steht sogar
titel g2 spyder jobs hintereinander oder
es auf dem bild drauf oder irgendwie
einen der letzten zehn folgen eventuell
tja man die kommentare stein welche
folge dass wir es noch willst dass wir
auf jeden fall einer der krassesten
erlebnisse die sie in minecraft hatte
dass ich zwei spiele hintereinander
gewonnen
es ist eine chance 0,0001
das ist eins in 10.000 das oder ist es
ein 10.000 das ist ein 10 10 100 das ist
eins in 10.000 ich habe eine 1 10.000
chance geträumt bin einfach nur total
pro laufmeter deshalb wieder sich jetzt
beim ersten effekt so ein bisschen
emotional geworden bin aber es ist
wirklich so ich erreicht nie imagefilm
icap dann hab ich aber so was geschafft
da ich schon ganz stolz drauf und es ist
halt einfach schon krass dass die chance
ein spyder jockey zu spannen bei 0,01
prozent und ich mal einfach zweiter
einander voll das war schon mega geil
jedenfalls kommen wir jetzt zu fact
nummer zwei und zwar sagt minecraft
wikis glätte können nicht durch ranken
sehen und zwar sehe schon da habe ich so
ein tolles skelett gesprochen und ich
bin eben game und 1 das heißt es treibt
mich eh nicht an
allerdings gehe ich jetzt mal in den
game center den spielmodus wurde
geändert und ihr seht schon das skelett
natürlich wenn ich mich hinstelle denkt
dass sich halo hey guck ich glaube dass
an und erschießt mich ab weil hier ist
ein spalt wenn ich dann allerdings
hingehe zu den ranken denkt dass nicht
nur der werkstatt noch nicht durchkommt
noch einmal sogar hierdurch die beiden
ranken durch da passt locker an pfeil
durch ist da ihr das hier damit sehe da
da ist kein spalt zwischen da kann sich
durch komme ich dann allerdings wieder
hier bin denkt jetzt bei der who ich
schieß dem ab dem pascha und dann bin
ich hier bin ich mir also der effekt ist
einfach skelette können nicht durch
ranken sehen schießen oder sonst
irgendwas machen der dritte weg wurde
mir zugesendet von einer person die
anonym bleiben möchte und zwar hat diese
person mit geschrieben die hat mir so
ein bild geschickt von seinem twitter
chat zwischen tobias hips und jason
adams aid in bonn von mo yan zwar tobias
hits geschrieben add on health academy
will switches blum steak switches
live-chat switches willst born in hat
und erst dann geschehen der dinnerbreak
in give you to the fairy also ich kann
dir zwei von drei davon bestätigen
also er hat quasi gesagt der tobi hat
gefragt kannst du mir davon etwas
versprechen und zwar erstens dass hexen
zauberbesen bekommen diese fliegel besen
zweitens die werden
so katzen als haustiere haben oder
drittens die werden in so hüten spawnen
und der dinner bonn hat gesagt ich kann
dir zwei von drei davon versprechen das
einzige was er vermisse eingetreten ist
ist das hexen in hütten spawnen das
heißt eine von den anderen sachen wie
die man hinzugefügt also entweder dass
sie zauberbesen links haben oder dass
sie so kleine katzen haben ich meine
hexen haben noch keine katzen das ist
nur mit mods bisher hinzugefügt wenn es
noch nicht so ist dann richtig mich
allerdings wird in zukunft eine von den
beiden sachen auf jeden fall eine
neuerung bei den hexen darstellen das
heißt ich habe euch schon mal kleine
sneak peek gegebene chance in der
nächsten version von my kommen könnte
ich hoffe aber dass dieser boom sticks
kommen dass die hexen irgendwie wenn sie
einmal ganz wenig leben haben versuchen
wegzufliegen oder so aber ganz langsam
super boden und so oder so ein besen
richtig fressen kann
der vierte fällt es aus dem minecraft
wickie und zwar ist es kein weg den ich
euch vorstellen möchte sondern ich
möchte diesen effekt widerlegen
ich freue mich einfach mal so eine tolle
neue spinne ihr seht das ist arg ich
kann gegen die gegend laufen ich bin dem
game 0 die macht nichts aus wenn ich sie
angreife denke sie hat nicht angegriffen
bleibt wie auch andere ich schlag
einfach drauf und dies tut man nicht
allerdings jetzt mal eine spinne hier
hinsetzen und werfe die mit schneebällen
ab wird die ebenfalls aggressiv und wenn
ich sie mit eiern abwärtsfahrt ich würde
ich mal selbst es bei schneefällen
gesehen und wenn ich sie mit eiern
abwerfe seht ihr auch schon da wird die
auch aggressiv und greift nicht auch an
nicht würdig mal ganz kurz bevor die
mich tötet allerdings ich blende euch
das jetzt mal ein was im micro forum
steht und zwar wenn der spieler ein ei
auf eine spinne wirft bleibt diese
neutral
die haben keinen plan in emmendingen
wiki von euch also rein theoretisch bei
micro bikini mal vorbei fahren können
und ob glock ihr habt keine ahnung dann
sagt ihr auf jeden fall mal dass sie das
da rausnehmen sollen weil ich dachte mir
okay cool hast effekt aber es geht
einfach nicht aber es ist natürlich auch
ein fake dass es nicht geht also
eigentlich ist alles einfällt was man
machen kann aber dass auf jeden fall
hektar 4 dass das nicht geht 5 defekt
wurde mir von einer person zugesendet
die anonym bleiben möchte und zwar ist
es dieser befehl ich war nein nicht
times at night ich von dir dieser befehl
so jamann und hat mir gezeigt wie man in
minecraft die uhrzeit umstellen kann
etwas total neues für mich jedenfalls
besagt dass dieses nicht in dieses geld
sondern dieser befehlshabern also dass
sie etwas erschaffe ein skelett mit den
drei wellen aber das noch dazu kommt
oder planung es hat auf jeden fall das
equipment id blablabla riding was diese
skelette reihte das heißt wenn ich hier
draufklicken kann ich einfach in spider
jackies poren und das coole ist bei
diesem befehl ich kann auch hier
eingeben einfach mal anstatt der spyder
gebe ich das seien 1
und anstatt dem skelett kann ich da
beispielsweise einfach mal noch mal
seien eingeben und jetzt habe ich quasi
eine giganten der einen gegangen hätte
das ist einfach so witzig das wäre auf
jeden fall ich habe vor zwei folgen
irgendwann gesagt ja ob ihr bockhop auf
eine command serie
das wäre ein richtiger command ich
glaube ja der wehr auch in seiner folge
auf jeden fall mit rangekommen oder kam
die command serie schauen sie kam noch
nicht ich hab mir da zurzeit alles am
fahrplan so ein bisschen urlaub und
brown jedenfalls können wir hier mit
extrem viele coole sachen erzeugen kann
auch einfach mal hier creeper eingeben
und hier rein theoretisch ja ich bin mir
nicht sicher ob das geht und es geht
einfach der gast reitet einen creeper
alter und interessen gehabt der einen
giganten reiter und skater jogger und
willst du das traurig ist difficulty 0
und alle sind die fischer mit allen
möglichen mops machen mit allen
möglichen
geht das mit entities überhaupt alba das
weltklasse noch einmal seine rüstung
ständern krieg bereitet die idee von von
rüstung ständer ist naja egal ich würde
auf jeden fall sagen meine lieben
freunde das w st on command der einfach
dann auch in diesem fall die commands
video rein kommen ich würde einfach
sagen alle lieben freunde wenn euch
diese folge minecraft ex gefallen hat
zeigt es mir mit einer bewertung der sec
mir mal das es euch gefallen hat wenn
ihr einen coolen fest schaut mal in die
beschreibung lässt das formular
ausfüllen können und nicht mehr
ein effekt ein und ich würde sagen wir
sehen uns in einem weiteren video wieder
wenn es wieder heißt